hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
death if we wanted to be somewhat
facetious we could call
one of the great mysteries of life and
part of our existential condition
it's one of those ultimate things that
shestop thinks we don't really know that
much more about
than our great great ancestors did and
at the same time it's inescapable and we
have to try to grapple with it
typically we do so through the modality
not just of mourning with other people
which he doesn't talk that much about in
this work
but fear fear of our own death fear of
what death
means and he's got a passage chapter 63
in part one
where he says fear of death is explained
conclusively
by the desire for self-preservation he's
not saying that he actually buys this
this is what other people are putting
forth it's it's self-preservation
every living thing tries to maintain
itself
in its being we have a natural instinct
to avoid
death and what is dangerous to us and
then he says
you know if that was really the case
then the fear should disappear
in old and sick people who ought to by
nature
look with indifference upon death
whereas the horror of death
is present in all living things
so here's some important counter
examples
the closer that people do get to their
death the
more in some cases they're actually
preoccupied with it they fear it
all the more so he says doesn't this
suggest that there's still some other
reason for the dread
and that even where the pains of horror
cannot save a person from their end
still it's a necessary and purposeful
anguish
anxiety worry concern
there isn't any sort of natural
scientific reductive explanation that's
going to make
sense out of death and then he says the
natural scientific explanation here
as usual stops halfway and fails to lead
the human mind
to the promised goal we don't really
know why we're so anxious
so afraid of death modern scientific
explanations are not going to be
particularly helpful in another
important passage he's going to tell us
that
modern science wants to sort of
tranquilize
us when it comes to death he tells us
here we go this is in chapter 72
he says that modern science forbids men
to fear and insists on a tranquil
attitude
and we arrive at utilitarianism and the
positivist philosophy
utilitarianism that doesn't do any good
to be worried about death
and the positives philosophy don't say
anything
that isn't purely positive that is
something that you know
in the present or your you know recent
experience something that could be
scientifically adjusted
everything else is really metaphysical
or religious mumbo jumbo that you should
put aside
be an adult that's the way the
positivists framed things
and schuster says you know
that is an attitude somebody can take i
don't know that everyone can be
as conclusive about that as a matter of
fact our existential condition
means that the technologists the lab
rats
the people who are you know pushing the
scientific point of view
since they do have to live as human
beings
thirstily longing to get out of the
enclosure of positive knowledge
they have to deal with the fact that we
are going to die science can't give us
the last word on that he says humankind
has no means by which to perform on
itself such a monstrous castration right
you can't
get rid of death and our
normal typical fears about it
so even the people who are pushing this
scientific point of view
if they are able to live it through
that's really a rarity
so interestingly in this very chapter he
talks about
the criticisms of gogol another russian
author uh he says that gogol succumbs to
the fear of death of
devils and of hell and shastaff says you
know
that's actually an on point criticism
i find the accusation just google
definitely feared
death demons and hell and then chester
gives you a little bit of a twist he
says
it's not really whether he did that we
have to make an additional assumption
here that
he was wrong in doing that maybe fear of
death
devil's hell can actually be
all right maybe that can be what we
ought to do
i mean we can have all sorts of
different configurations doesn't
necessarily have to be dante's inferno
with all the different levels
i mean if you look across religions
you're going to find that
it's not just christianity or even the
abrahamic monotheistic religions that
have hells
it's pretty widespread and i'm not just
talking about say
you know greco-roman religion or
anything like that you look at religions
that have reincarnation like buddhism
and hinduism
and there are multiple hells in which a
person can find themselves
and multiple beings that would carry out
torments and death
at the center of that so these fears
that human beings have
we're not saying that they're
necessarily rational they're definitely
not scientific
but it's not as if modern science can
just wave its
its magic wand and say these are to be
dispelled
as irrational and so you know
he says the point is whether it's not
right to fear these things and whether
fearlessness would be a proof
of the high development of a person's
soul he says schopenhauer asserts death
inspired philosophy all the best poetry
the wonderful mythology of the ancients
and modern people have further source
the fear of death only modern science
forbids people to fear and insist on a
tranquil attitude towards death
we could also add into that certain
philosophies
that denigrated the fear of death
epicureanism stoicism
you know these are our philosophies that
that
could also be lumped in there with
modern science in saying don't worry
about this sort of thing
he also talks about philosophers and
whether they had
good deaths and whether their their
ideas about
death were particularly on point and
this is kind of interesting this is
chapter five right
he talks about um plato's
last conversations plato's account of
the last conversations the socrates
the days the hours of the old man are
numbered and yet he talks
talks talks he talks about credo and
that
uh he talks about the fado he says
it could be that plato's not all
together to be trusted
but we have it from other sources that
socrates spent the month following his
verdict
in incessant conversations with his
pupils and friends
that is what it is to be a beloved
master and have disciples
you can't even die quietly
so is this the best way to to live out
one's last moments and cross the
threshold into death
shastaff actually seems to be saying no
that's that's not the best thing
he actually also brings up pascal says
pascal pascal's his sister
tells us talked a great deal before his
death dimousset
cried like a baby perhaps here's an
interesting suggestion
socrates and pascal talked so much for
fear
they would start crying because crying
would at least be
sort of a authentic reaction to the fact
that you're going to die
and you're going to leave behind what
your disciples
your ideas
interestingly at an another point this
is in uh chapter
25 he talks about um
death this this sort of you know truism
of death being
the inspiration of philosophers
he says it's become a platitude that
fear of death is the inspiration of
philosophers
numberless quotations could be drawn
from ancient modern
writers if they were necessary maybe the
poetic dimon of socrates which made him
wise was only fear
personified and then he talks about
tolstoy as well and he says
if if we were in socrates time maybe
tolstoy would be talking about
a dimon or his dreams and steady squares
his accounts with science and morality
in place of
gods and demons the last thing that he
says that's really
interesting about philosophers
and death is that their ideas are left
behind
as if those are their legacy this is in
chapter 18 of part one he says that
ideas whether proven or not are the
dearest possession in life to them
in sorrow of consolation and difficulty
a source of counsel
even death is not terrible to ideas
they will follow a person beyond the
grave
they are the only imperishable riches
so think about socrates and his
discussion of
uh you know that the ideas that he's put
forth are not going to go away
and people are going to pick them up and
continue criticizing his fellow
athenians plato is writing you might say
to to keep ideas in the world after him
and so many other philosophers he says
all this the philosophers repeat very
eloquently
repeat and reiterate concerning their
ideas no less skillfully than advocates
plead their cases on behalf of thieves
and swindlers right that these ideas are
what are going to live
they are going to be their legacy
shoutoff
actually has a different suggestion for
us
and this is a bit later this is in part
two
of the work in a chapter called death
and metaphysics chapter
37 he tells us that
the the roads to good things are
dangerous to
travel and so he says that the more
alluring an
end we have in view the more risks and
horrors we must undertake to get there
let's make a contrary suggestion behind
every danger
something good is hidden danger serves
as an indication
a mark to guide us onward not as a
warning as we're taught to
believe now what does this have to do
with death he immediately tells us
to decide this would be to decide that
behind death
the greatest of dangers must lie the
most promising things
and then he says it's as well not to
speculate further
we best stop lest we quarrel with
metaphysics
we don't actually know what's going to
happen when we die but maybe it's
actually not that bad maybe we don't
have to console ourselves with
imaginations like well i'm going to be
in heaven or down you know in hades and
argue with
all of the old ghosts and find out you
know whether achilles was really as
brave as they say the way socrates says
maybe we don't have to project all sorts
of things
out there for ourselves but perhaps
there is something good there for us
and now this is very interesting and
this is well worth
closing these reflections on he tells us
we must make use of
everything to serve the ends of this
life of ours and in the middle of that
he interjects even of death
we must make use of everything even of
death
to serve the ends of this life of ours
we you know if fear of death inspires
philosophizing
that's great it doesn't have to turn
into some sort of rigid
approach to things that we're engaging
in basically to try to put those fears
at rest maybe it's okay to be afraid of
hell
and the devil and death maybe it's even
afraid
okay to be afraid of what if i get into
heaven and i'm bored there
you know that's that's also a
possibility is it not right
or what if i get to heaven and find out
i was totally wrong about religion
i was an atheist and then there's god
what do i do you know
these it's perfectly fine to speculate
about these things
we can make use of death which we're
going to face eventually
to live a fuller better more
thoughtful life
you